cells in order to fulfill their
metabolic needs always they require
amino acids water molecule several ions
to be transported inside of the cell and
also they need to eject out their toxic
product or metabolic waste that is
produced inside the cell so movement of
ions water molecules and other amino
acids is important process for cellular
physiology but there is a fundamental
problem for example if we think about a
plasma membrane only the lipid bilayer
then only some gaseous molecule like
oxygen carbon dioxide nitrogen can pass
easily through out the membrane via
diffusion but if we think about
diffusion of small uncharged especially
polar molecules like water urea or
glycerol it is very hard for them to
passively diffuse across the membrane
the main reason for this is water
Yury or anything it they are kind of
polar but the membrane head group is
only the polar group but while they
would Traverse across the lipid bilayer
they would also encounter the
hydrophobic tails now that would make
them so uncomfortable and that is why
the rate of diffusion is ultra slow now
large unconsumed uncharged polar
molecules such as glucose sucrose
etcetera etcetera sugar molecules can
also pass through the membrane
now small ions like hydrogen potassium
sodium chloride etc or them the membrane
is almost impermeable for passive
diffusion then how to sell actually take
up these ions or these nutrients from
the environment so definitely cell need
transport methods and somebody to help
or facilitate the transports so before
going to that we should understand what
is the thermodynamic constraints of
transporting ions
across the membrane imagine we have a
sodium ion and we want this sodium ion
to be traversing across the membrane by
passive diffusion and reach the inside
of the cell so but we cannot imagine the
sodium ion to be isolated in the
environment because it is always
interacting with the water molecule and
forming a hydration shell around the
sodium ion now the sodium ion when gets
inside the membrane leaflet then it's a
uneasy situation because the sodium ion
is charged
where are the lipid bilayer the inside
of the lipid bilayer is extremely
hydrophobic environment which makes the
sodium ion very unstable and it creates
a huge energy barrier for diffusion
no matter what after the sodium ion goes
inside it also has to regain the
hydration shell so all of these
criterias poses pose a huge energy
barrier now in terms of Gibbs free
energy we can understand the Gibbs free
energy change for this passive diffusion
is pretty high and it's very hard to
achieve this kind of energy change to
move the ions across the membrane but
cells are clever
they'll have specific transporters ion
channels etc so if we think about ion
channel it creates a unique environment
for passage of this ion and it's
extremely selective as well we would be
learning about the selectivity mechanism
later but it can get rid of the
hydration shell and easily allow the
passage of the sodium ion or any other
cat ion across the membrane and the for
this process the energy change is pretty
low as well so this is more favorable
than passive diffusion and hundred times
more fast now if we talk about the
transport
or the ways of transport we should talk
about passive transport and active
transport passive transport takes place
along the concentration gradient so
let's say the ions would move along the
concentration gradient and most of the
cases this concentration gradient is the
most important driving force for the
ionic movement now for active transport
it requires ATP or it's for the ionic
transport and it can drive the ions to
move against the concentration gradient
itself and the energy that is required
to move the ions against the
concentration gradient comes from the
ATP hydrolysis so without ATP hydrolysis
active transport cannot takes place and
passive transport don't require ATP
hydrolysis but what is similar between
these two process is both of them need
some kind of transporter to transport
the ions or specific molecules that is
the similarity between that now we try
to understand the forces that is acting
upon the ions when ionic movement
happens across the plasma membrane we
imagine a portion of the neuronal
membrane so there are two kind of course
we can imagine one is the electrical
force which is due to the charge
separation across the membrane and this
electrical force is actually Q times the
potential gradient difference and other
than that there is a chemical gradient
force due to chemical gradient as well
and these two force try to balance each
other now for example we take an example
of a potassium ion now in the situation
one let's say the potential of the
membrane is now reduced from zero
millivolt to minus 90 milli volt so now
the membrane becomes more a kind of
negative that will increase the tendency
of this ion to be attracted towards this
membrane whereas in the situation too if
the membrane potential is made more
positive then
would happen the production would be
repelled away right now apart from the
electrical force the forces due to
chemical gradient is also very important
and for example potassium ion is more in
the cytoplasm than the external
environment and that is why there is a
into outward gradient exist or potassium
ion movement now we can calculate the
exact membrane potential depending upon
the concentration of the ion and we can
calculate an a particular hypothetical
point which is known as a reversal
potential a potential where there is no
net and if movement where the chemical
forces and the electrical forces balance
each other now since we know the
potassium concentration in the inside
and the outside of the cell we can kind
of understand the reversal potential of
potassium is very close to minus 90
millivolts and a battery of ionic
potentials actually governed the resting
membrane potential of the neurons itself
now we talked about the transporters
which transport the ions across the
membrane so the concept of transporters
is simple so the transporter can by can
bind to the ion and it can undergo a
conformational change that would allow
the release of ion on the other hand
side of ions or other molecules in the
outside of the cell at the inside of the
cell now the mode of the transport could
be three different types for example
UNEP ort muna port means you need
directional transport symport means two
molecules are simultaneously transported
in the same direction let's say inside
of the cell an anti port is just
opposite to support like one molecule is
going out of the cell one molecule is
getting inside of the cell so we would
try to see and whether we can understand
all of these modes of transport by
several examples first we look at uni
port so the RPC need to be
metabolically active and in order to
perform all the metabolic and means it
need glucose to be entering inside the
RBC cells right and this happens via a
glute one and glute one transporter is
present in the RBC membrane so this is
an example of facilitated diffusion as
well and here the glute one transporter
is the important factor so glucose bind
to the glute one transporter it
undergoes a conformational change and
kind of opens inside of the cell
releasing them to Lucas molecules to the
inner side of the cell and that is how
the transport of glucose takes place in
the RPC cell membrane and it is
physiologically relevant and you can
understand the directionality is from
outside to inside so it's a uni part
right think about another example for
example why we think the lysosome can
maintain a very acidic environment on
the lysosome membrane there are several
transporters among them one of the most
important is a V type ATP's which pumps
in hydrogen ion inside of the lysosome
and that is how it can create a low pH
environment an acidic environment now
this is also an import because the
hydrogen ion movement is from outside to
inside but the difference between this
transport versus ters loop one
transporter is the following
here the hydrogen can only pass if ATP
is hydrolyzed so this is ATP driven so
this kind of muna port is an active
transport as well we try to take example
of a simple now we look at the
intestinal cross section now here is the
cross section of you here is the cross
section of your intestine here you can
see the intestinal epithelial cells now
intestinal epithelial cells have s glt
or sodium dependent mucus transporter
now this suit look dependent Lucas
transporter
can take sodium along with glucose and
both bind to the transporter that lead
to a conformational change which
ultimately release glucose as well as
sodium inside of the cell and that is
how we absorb glucose and sodium in
simultaneously in our ink stein list at
the last we talked about the antiport in
antiport the movement direction is just
the opposite one is going out one is
coming in so we talked in context of
neuronal membrane so in the neuronal
membrane there are plenty of sodium
potassium ion exchange pumps or sodium
potassium ATPase so these eight EPA's
need can this ATP s has sodium binding
pockets where three sodium ions can bind
from inside followed by an ATP
hydrolysis which would trigger the
confirmation change and that leads the
sodium ion to be released outside
whereas at other hand side potassium ion
can bind to the altered state of this
sodium potassium ATPase and followed by
a conformational change which would
allow the potassium ion to get inside of
the cell and this is how the inside of
the cell is receiving more potassium ion
and pumping out sodium ion so whatever
you can see is that more positive charge
are trained out of the neuronal membrane
right so the neuronal membrane is kind
of at the resting state possess a
negative potential and that is how
resting membrane potential is negative
now we talked about ion channels right
now so there are voltage-gated ion
channels which open or close depend upon
the voltage difference across the
membrane
so here the ion channel has taken in an
iron and it's conformational change lead
to release of the ion in the other hand
side now there are ligand gated ion
channel which open or closed due to
binding of a ligand
now here the ligand binds and as a
result the conformation on the other
hand side has changed which
to ionic influx through that channel now
you can find voltage-gated ion channels
all across the axon all across the
length of their ground axon in a new one
but as you can find the ligand gated ion
channels especially specifically in the
postsynaptic region so these are a few
examples of several transporters several
carriers and channels used for ionic
transport and transport of other
important molecules for the cell I hope
you enjoyed this introductory video if
you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you